gas prices continue to set records with
the national average crossing about five
dollars per gallon right now here in las
vegas we're much higher at about
5.59 per gallon that's up 45 cents from
a month ago and 2.23 cents from one year
so the question is can local officials
do anything to provide relief the 8 news
now i-team's vanessa murphy breaks down
the gas taxes
while some states have been reducing or
suspending their gas taxes during our
record high prices clark county drivers
will be getting a gas tax hike soon in
2016 voters made the choice to raise our
gas tax every year to pay for roads
through 2026 and that increase goes up
as inflation goes up the next increase
is july 1st an extra 1.6 cents a gallon
here's a breakdown of taxes you pay per
gallon of gas right now 68 cents of
every gallon goes to clark county 23
cents goes to the state of nevada and
the federal government takes 18 and a
half cents so about a dollar and 10
cents of every gallon is in taxes as for
the state tax suspending or reducing it
would have to be done by state lawmakers
as for the federal tax suspending it
wouldn't do nevadans any good because we
have a state law automatically raising
the state tax to offset any drop in the
federal one as for the county tax the
regional transportation commission says
it's researching what would have to
happen to reduce or suspend it